hello and welcome back to steampunks the
GameSpot show where we go through the
last seven days of steamed new releases
and tell you our favorites I'm Edmund
Tran and lots of good games this week so
many good games one of which was far
learn sales so this is a really gorgeous
side scroller that's basically about
maintaining your vehicle in a kind of
post-apocalyptic environment you find
yourself in this kind of bleak limbo
inside esque environment where you
appear to be the last survivor and hop
in an old steam powered vehicle and
basically you want to keep moving
forward work to keep it functional
through hazardous weather obstacles and
increasingly complicated puzzles as I
mentioned this game is crazy reminiscent
of inside music is used deliberately and
sparingly and it's often a tool to let
you know you're on the right track
because other than that there are no
indicators of how you should proceed or
how you should use anything to do with
your vehicle so you really need to learn
by doing it's really effective and
really nice to see a game that trusts
its players one of the really
interesting things I like is there's no
fabricated enemy so you are in what
appears to be the post apocalypse but
there's no zombies there's no evil
overlord situation like there is in
inside and instead you're just motivated
by trying to survive and trying to move
forward which is really nice it's a
peaceful game it's a peaceful game but
what you are fighting against is the
environment and the stress of making
sure your vehicle can keep going so
there are a couple of ways you can do
that you can stock it with energy so it
moves forward through a locomotive
system and it also has sails on top of
it and other things that you can add to
it along the way the environments are
absolutely beautiful I love the look of
this game your protagonist is also
really adorable and one of the things
that's a really nice touch is you don't
have to worry about full damage if
you're ever coming down from a height
her skirt just floats whenever she comes
down which is really cute wait
you die in this game like and you run
out of like energy you can run out of
energy and then you just get stuck but
this game isn't a roguelike
it wants you to move forward and it auto
saves a lot I was actually really
overcome at the end
it's cry I did cry I cried a lot it's
kind of this feeling of like relief and
sadness and exhaustion in my opinion the
puzzles that come up are just hard
enough and interpreting what's going on
from the environmental Clues is
intriguing
initially the slow pace that kind of
serves as cutscenes when you're just
going from place to place or you don't
have to worry too much about an
environmental hazard bothered me but it
really does become almost like a
meditative process making the loop from
like your engine button to your steam
valve so the steam doesn't overload back
to your fuel deposit tree up to the
sails and back again it's kind of a nice
little process one thing to be aware of
is the runtime is really short it's 2 to
3 hours long so this is a $15 game which
I feel like is totally worth it but if
you want more bang for your buck that's
something to be aware of that said this
is probably my favorite game I've played
on the show so far it is so touching it
delivers a ton of heart without trying
too hard
and it has a lot of interesting moving
parts
all right so that game didn't have
anybody chasing you at all but the game
I played had lots of people chasing you
all the time and it's your problem to
deal with
this is framed collection as the name
suggests it's a collection of two games
called framed framed one and two and
they're both puzzle games that revolve
around the same concept so that's a
rating a collection of comic book panels
to get different outcomes the gist of
the narrative is that you're some kind
of nameless thief and you're trying to
elude the police and not kill yourself
in the process and by default each
puzzle page of the sort of comic frames
as you die or get captured or something
like that so you might have already
played this on smartphones it came out a
while ago and most famously hideo kojima
of Metal Gear Solid Fame called it his
game of the year in 2014 so what you do
with the game is you play with the order
of the panels to see what happens for
the protagonist as he encounters the
different objects and their different
frames instead of different orders and
those are my goals to get the
protagonist the last panel and get them
to go to the next page and it's
definitely satisfying when you actually
hit the correct solution instead of work
it out one thing that frame collection
adds to the games is a fast-forward
button that lets you zoom through the
panels which I didn't have on smartphone
so it makes it experimenting a little
bit more bearable and eventually these
puzzles added more mechanics so you'll
get panels that can be either used
horizontally or vertically you get the
ability to sort of move panels while the
guy or girl is still running through
them and you might get the ability to
sort of manipulate the actual
environment that they're running in so
like turning the hands of a clock to use
him as a platform the game looks really
great has a really strong presentation
and the animation is very nice to look
at and the jazzy soundtrack really
rounds that out it doesn't cost a whole
lot it's only ten bucks on Steam and
it's also one switch so if you like a
look of it it's a pretty worthwhile
impulse buy
[Music]
that sounds pretty straightforward yep I
mean I know it's straight focus I've
played it
what it's not straightforward is the
second game I played this week called
omen site but it is a great time it's an
action murder-mystery which is a genre
you don't hear about too much where the
world is about to end in fact it has
ended and you play as the Harbinger who
needs to save the world before it's
doomed to this super demon Vodun so
you'll dig into the final days of four
key characters to discover who killed
the godless priestess as this which I
sent you on a mission that if you save
her you'll save the world this is a
spiritual successor to stories which was
a cult hit with a similar look and feel
this is very bright and fast-paced which
is nice the realm is also populated by
dog and cat people who are fighting rat
people which makes you think that it's
like really just light-hearted and jokey
but it's actually quite a seriously
toned game and it has a pretty engaging
story that I have found personally to be
quite addictive so you'll play through
the entire day with any of the given
characters and then when it gets to the
end of it you will take that knowledge
with you to go into someone else's day
but you don't really need to worry about
racing against a clock so for every
niggling thing in this game like the
many fixed beyond good and evil ask
camera angles that bothered the crap out
of me there's a lot of cool stuff like
when you go hang out with the noble cat
general she judges you for looting
chests and there's some really funny
well-written dialogue the voice acting
is hit or miss the hits are great thanks
to some really good voice work talents
like Patricia Somerset from birth the
wild and writing from Chris abalone
among a bunch of other heavy hitters so
this is mainly an action game with some
light platforming and fighting is for
the most part pretty slick and enjoyable
especially since every time you come
back to base after you've experienced
another day you'll be able to meditate
and put the points you've earned by
killing dudes into getting extra levels
that grants you new abilities that focus
on speed attack chaining time
manipulation and just a bunch of brand
new things that make fighting way more
interesting just don't try using a mouse
and keyboard so I'm a mouse and keyboard
Evo
this game is not suited for it it tells
you at the very beginning not to you'll
also be able to grant these characters
than knowledge you gain as you go so you
can skip them ahead to doing different
things in their day so it is rare that
you'll be repeating exactly the same
story with these characters and when you
do have to do that the game gives you
the option to skip to the critical
moment so you don't have to play through
the same stuff unless you really want to
and the entire game will have you
jumping between a relatively small
amount of different locations but the
sequences for each of the four
characters aren't too long that it
becomes tiresome to see the same enemies
in the same areas so this one is 20
bucks which is a pretty good time if
you're into these kind of games where
you just kill a bunch of dudes using
different abilities and the story is
actually more engaging than most games I
played from this genre so I would
definitely recommend it if you're into
this kind of thing
[Music]
well killing dudes was a bunch of
different abilities is something that I
like doing and I really love doing in
this next one which is called wizard of
legend so wizard of legend is a very
fast-paced dungeon crawler roguelike
where you play a really cool wizard with
a collection of different spells to you
to kill dude the game's description
actually calls this game no-nonsense
which I find pretty apt it just gets
straight into it there's it starts up in
this museum area which talks about the
game sort of mechanics like they were
like aged in the history exhibits and
then before too long you just dump the
magic world and you get to do everything
from Rio which I quite like so even
though your wizard this play is much
more like a brawler or a fighting game
you move really quickly are you attack
really quickly and you have a bunch of
different magics that you can fire off
very quickly so it's about sort of calm
bowing and chaining your attacks and
abilities you actually have a few
different slots to assign your econo
abilities to they're apparently over a
hundred unique abilities with a split in
two different elements and each also has
its typical vulnerability to one another
so water is weak to lightning and strong
to fire for example so from the get-go
your arsenal is very customizable you
can change all your attacks and
abilities you have slots for your basic
attack you - move a couple for your
standard spells and your signature
ability which is kind of like standard
spell but also doubles as your ultimate
ability when you kill enough enemies to
power it up the progression kind of
looks like this you go down into a
randomly generated dungeon you explore
it and try and clear it as much as
possible before fighting a boss and then
getting access to the next level and
every three stages you do will take on
one of this major three elemental
council members who are basically the
big bosses in terms of its roguelike
structure there are two currencies that
you collect as you go there are gems and
there are coins so gems are persistent
between runs and coins are only good for
that run gems are used to buy stuff like
new spells and stat boosting equipment
in the shops that appear before you set
out on a run you permanently get to keep
all those things while coins used to buy
[ __ ] and dungeon shops it's also on
switch and other consoles as well as
steam which is great if you'd like to
play games on the train like me and it
will run you about 16 bucks it's a this
is one I would definitely recommend if
you like action games
[Music]
sweet
well that is everything we've got for
this week do let us know if there's any
games you had your eye on for the last
week all the week coming up that you
think we should check out my name is
Jess McDonald I made me Tran and we will
see you again next week
[Music]
[Music]